Speaker 1: There was a new CPAC straw poll
done this weekend at CPAC, and although Donald
Trump is still leading the 2024 presidential
straw poll.
Ron DeSantis is polling higher than ever before
28 percent and Trump is furious.
So we want to kind of consider this story
in the right context.
Trump is still winning the straw poll, but
the margin by which he is winning it for the
2024 Republican primary is as small as it
has ever been.
The Hill reporting Trump wins CPAC straw poll
As the Santos's support grows, former President
Trump emerged as the clear winner.
But Ron DeSantis is now up to 28 percent recall,
as the article does, that in last year's straw
poll.
DeSantis had 21 percent support.
In third place was Trump's former Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo, with two percent support.
So Trump has been furious about what's going
on with the scientists for a long time now.
You might remember that in November, I reported
to you, Trump's ire grows as DeSantis.
His popularity with Republicans takes off,
and at that point, DeSantis was only polling
between 10 and 20 for the 2024 Republican
primary debate.
Sending which poll you looked at and what's
at issue here and what Trump is so enraged
by is that a number of times now when DeSantis
has been asked Do you rule out running for
president in general or do you rule out running
if Trump runs and DeSantis has not ruled out
either?
And why would he, when you're polling 28 percent
and it's years from the election and you haven't
even really talked about running, you genuinely
have a good shot at being the Republican nominee.
DeSantis would be crazy if he has any even
possibility of ambitions to be the Republican
nominee in 2024.
DeSantis would be crazy to rule it out, so
of course he hasn't.
And Trump's furious since then, Trump has
gone at DeSantis, and DeSantis has also gone
after Trump, saying things like, for example,
DeSantis.
I don't know that I should have aligned myself
so closely with Trump early in the pandemic
might have not been the right decision.
Trump going back at the Santas, the order
doesn't matter, but going at each other, saying,
you know, he's ungrateful, and he didn't really
even do that great of a job with the pandemic
or whatever the case may be.
And one great way to trigger Donald Trump
is to not be 100 percent subservient in every
single way.
And Don Ron DeSantis, I've said before, I
believe Ron DeSantis is sort of like a more
dangerous version of Donald Trump in the sense
that it's the same wacky right wing ism completely
disconnected from reality, facts, empiricism,
etc..
But DeSantis is slightly less cartoonish than
Trump.
He's still a cartoon.
I mean, compared to, you know, old school
Republicans, DeSantis is still a total cartoon,
but he is more competent.
He's less obviously clueless, and he might
be more able to actually get things done in
the sort of Trumpian vein, and that makes
him a very dangerous guy.
So are the the prospects for the country are,
of course, concerning in the sense that when
a governor with endless unnecessary COVID
deaths is seeing his popularity take off,
that should raise a red flag for all of us.
At the same time, we saw 70 million people
vote for the completely moronic Donald Trump,
who has even more deaths than that on his
hands with his sheer incompetence on the pandemic.
And so it's been a serious problem for a while.
I do think that one of the best possible scenarios
for the left and for the Democratic Party
because the left in the Democratic Party are
really not indicating to me that they have
any ability to seriously win an election unless
someone really helps them out.
I'm hoping for help from the Republican Party
for Democrats in 2022 and 2024, and one of
the best things I can think of that would
happen would be that Trump and DeSantis get
into a really protracted primary battle.
And when we're already talking about 56 28,
I mean, Trump still winning but 56 28 this
far out from 2024 signals that DeSantis really
could be a very solid challenger to Trump.
And I think Democrats have to hope for absolutely
anything they can to help them out.
What will ultimately happen?
I think we won't know until after the 2022
midterms, and this is again why I continued
telling you guys in in some way.
Trump seems determined to run in 2024.
Even at the CPAC speech over the weekend,
Trump said in the clearest terms we've heard
so far.
We did it twice and we're going to do it again
in November of 2024.
I have not heard Trump more clearly and forcefully
say I plan to run than that.
At the same time, I do believe that if the
Trumpian wing and Trump's endorses get crushed
in November, I think Michael Cohen is right.
Remember when I spoke to Michael Cohen, Michael
Cohen said he doesn't think Trump will run
because Trump can't stand losing again.
And of course, the question is, will Trump
believe that he can win, or will Trump come
to realize that he's destined to lose?
And on that basis, what will he decide in
the immediate?
The best thing we can do is minimize losses
in November.
Maximize wins if there are wins to be had
and foment this split between DeSantis and
Trump because we have very little else to
be shooting for right now, I wish it were.
I wish it were different.
But that is the reality.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
After this short break, I will deliver the
state of the show address and tonight I'll
be live with Joe Biden's State of the Union
address on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I hope you'll join me
for that.